The joe rogan experience.
A lot of those rules that were were very
practical back and they not even sure
it was because you didn't want to
kiss the Kenosis exact sexual laws.
Well,
you know the restrictions on sex where
just because you didn't want to catch
syphilis and things back in the day.
So no cutting and baby Dick Sense.
I don't know anything about cutting,
cutting,
sucking baby Dick,
all that does it.
You know that comes from Moses when
he cut his own penis to show his chef
Serbians to God in the Old Testament.
That's a very weird way to
show your serious speaking.
You don't have a friend,
Reykjavik Moses.
I heard of that before.
I've never had a break yet.
They kept rushed from the emergency room.
Does it ever get fixed?
Totally.
Or is it always kinda hooked?
It kind of curves to
the left a little bit.
Wow.
His balls literally
internal bleeding filled up.
Oh my purple Gecko skin.
That's why you gotta be kept
careful with crazy bitches.
You got to get double
under hooks on crazy bitch,
dude.
Crazy bitches riding you.
You gotta you gotta hold their ass.
But like a from [inaudible],
you know how you got to go plum?
You can't just do this
because if you do this,
there's too much lateral room.
This room keep her down.
I got to the story Gable grip,
the lower hips.
My buddy is huge.
You've met this guy,
I'm not going to say his
name and all these guys.
Six,
six,
two 70 shred away his weight.
People are gonna figure out who they are.
They won't figure it out.
So He's like,
he tells me,
he goes,
Bro,
this girl wants it so hard.
He goes,
I don't know what to do,
how hard.
He goes,
I'm going to film it next time.
So he films it and it's one of the
most disturbing videos I've ever seen.
I mean,
he's getting air.
Pirate him.
What am,
I'm like,
Dang.
A week later he calls me,
he goes,
dude,
get over here.
I rush over it.
What's the man?
He's on the ground butt butt naked.
Like what's the values
that video I showed you,
I was backing up,
missed my penis,
hit her ass,
broke his dick.
Ah,
my goodness.
So this is what I tell him.
I go,
Bro,
this is an easy fix,
right?
I,
I've,
I have no idea how to
handle us doctor shop.
Yeah.
Doctor Shop in the house.
Big Brown.
Dot.
Shove in the house.
I know this easy fix.
I'm going to step out of the room.
You put a little porno on,
you get erect.
We're just going to line it right
back there and went right back up.
Just like you fix a broken nose.
It's a great strategy.
Right,
right.
Makes Sense.
That's a great shot down the room.
10 minutes later I hear,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
So I call my doctor buddy.
I'm like,
Yo man club.
My buddy was hooking up with his girl,
broke his [inaudible]
like his testicles big.
Oh yeah man,
they're pretty big.
Let me see your Tescos man shows me
these things are the size of a grapefruit
and it looks like ghetto
purple dotted skin.
Oh,
rushing,
rushing the emergency room.
Cause internal bleeding.
And uh,
people thought we were just to gaze
both big dudes.
I'm not making this up.
I wish I could make this up.
He straddled in a Gurney like this,
right?
He's like this things hanging down.
It's filling up,
talking to this nurse comes in,
hey boys,
flaming,
flaming gay guy.
Right?
Which is whatever.
I'm cool with that.
Right.
Legs up in style.
If this is his broken penis.
This dude's like this.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
This is pretty bad.
Listen,
we'll get a doctor and
we'll be right back.
He's doing that to his boss and I'm like,
what is going on here?
Leaves doc comes in.
Old Dude.
I'm like,
oh,
thank God.
Dot comes in.
He goes,
yeah man,
this is really bad.
You.
Yeah.
The,
the nurse was Kinda,
uh,
you know,
he's grabbing a man.
It's insane how badly goes.
Whoa.
A nurse physically touched his penis,
touched
telescope nose deep and his in his,
on his dick.
And he goes,
wow,
I need to get the name of that
guy because that is not code here.
You should not be doing.
That.
Guy Just came in to dig,
scan
that.
The white jacket.
White jazz got an APP on his phone and
when anybody gets administered to the
hospital with a broken deck,
you fucking shows up,
puts on his lap dances this year.
All just comes in.
I go,
I gotta be honest man.
How did you get into
basically majoring in Dick's?
Like what role did you go down and he
said in Egypt or someplace in Egypt where
um,
there's a religion,
they might be Muslim,
I'm not sure.
But they get erections.
They think it's Dell,
the Satan's work.
And they break their dad's not in,
that's not Muslim religion.
That might be,
well no,
it's an extremist Muslim.
He was saying that her muzzle,
it just sounds like a dumb person who,
whatever it is,
it's another crazy cause he was
saying and these guys need help.
So he got into it because
he was exposed to it.
So these guys think it's Satan's work,
the devil's work.
They get erections,
snap their debt.
A lot of them die from internal bleeding.
He,
uh,
they brushed doctors down there.
So most urologists go down
to this part of the world.
That's a fix it guy.
Anyways,
my buddy Bob break,
he's all good.
Now the update of my friend,
all good.
They give him pills so he can't get an
erection for six weeks and his dick was
in a splint.
Really?
A splints.
Splints has a hook.
Yeah.
So I'd hook or a big one.
Ah,
notice the ball.
Oh,
it's definitely knows.
What's that operation?
You can cut the tendon and it makes your
Dick longer gets foreign around your
tickets hard,
and it goes straight down.
That was a complication.
How much longer could it make it?
You got to jerk off downward,
Huh?
How much longer could it make?
You're not going to answer.
And Institute is,
you can cut the tendon that will
actually create more lengthier Dick.
But the problem was that the,
well,
for whatever reason,
the tenant is one of the instrumental
tenants and keeping it very hot.
You know,
I wreck,
you would think they would build
some sort of implant for that.
By now they have implants,
root thing else.
People are so fucking weird.
Yeah.